the retracted study claimed a large
sample size with data on 154 856
subjects for assessing the cancer risk
of vaping versus traditional smoking but
we should be looking at our Vapors who
never smoked traditional cigarettes and
yet have cancer there were 180 Vapors
with cancer in the study but based on
general population percentages probably
fewer than a hundred of them had never
smoked traditional cigarettes that's too
small a sample to draw robust
conclusions the median age of vapors in
the study was 25 versus 62 for the
traditional smokers and they had very
different breakdowns of income race sex
and medical conditions adjusting for all
these factors would require a minimum of
a thousand observations if researchers
can query the same data sets and arrive
at completely bizarre results that are
as strong or even stronger than the ones
they're reporting they're doing
something wrong